ich bin unterwegs an
russlands-ostseeküste ob in Kaliningrad
St Petersburg oder wieburg überall
begegnet mir Urlaubsstimmung und das
obwohl das Land im Krieg ist ist es
Teilnahmslosigkeit oder Flucht vor den
Repressionen einer unsicheren Zukunft
vor den Realitäten des Krieges die
längst auch Russland erreicht haben
eine Drohne ist über meinem Kopf
explodiert Helm und Schädeldecke wurden
durchschlagen
hier wo Russland an die EU grenzt ist
die Abschottung vom Westen besonders
deutlich spürbar die Grenzen zwischen
Patriotismus und Propaganda sind
fließend
wir möchten sehr gerne Frieden aber was
soll man machen jetzt muss man eben den
Faschismus bekämpfen wir wissen nicht
wie offen die Menschen mit uns sprechen
werden denn Moskau Zensurgesetze stellen
alles unter Strafe was nicht der Haltung
des Regimes entspricht auch mit
westlichen Fernsehteams zu reden kann
schwerwiegende Konsequenzen haben wir
müssen davon ausgehen dass der
Geheimdienst uns beobachtet und finden
dennoch Menschen die sich kritisch zu
Putins Regime äußern
wir haben jetzt genau die gleiche
schwere Krankheit die eins Deutschland
[Musik]
in der Region Kaliningrad liegt seleno
Graz einer der hipsten Badeorte an der
russischen Ostsee hier bin ich mit einem
Pionier verabredet jefgeni isakov war
einer der ersten Surfer Russlands er
will allen beweisen dass Wellenreiten
auch in der kalten Ostsee Spaß macht
seine Kurse sind begehrt vor allem
seitdem Auslandsreisen für die meisten
Russinnen und Russen nicht mehr
erschwinglich sind im Sommer kümmert
sich giftgeni um seine Surfschule den
Rest des Jahres lebte in Indonesien
Deutsch hat er während seines Studiums
in Aachen gelernt
nachdem alles angefangen ist ich habe
meistens mit
Leute aus Asien gesprochen und die
soll das sagen sie sind an der Seite von
Russen und das ist nicht so dass Sie
also es ist ganz anders mit Ihnen wie
das in Europa genommen ist und ganz
anders wie in Asien Marina ist ganz neu
im Team erst vor wenigen Wochen hat die
23-Jährige ihre Arbeit als Ingenieurin
in der Moskauer Metro eingetauscht gegen
das Surferleben am Ostseestrand
wenn du das mit Moskau vergleichst das
sind alle traurig bedrückt hierher
kommen die Menschen um Urlaub zu machen
sich zu erholen daher kommen Sie mit
einem Lächeln auf dich zu schenken dir
Freude das macht dich dann auch
glücklich
einen Surf Wettkampf unter allen Ostsee
Anrainern wollte Jewgeni organisieren
diese Pläne liegen jetzt auf Eis
überhaupt sei das Leben in einigen
Bereichen komplizierter geworden manche
waren teurer manche Themen tabu aber der
40-Jährige kann sich arrangieren
ich kann verstehen dass jetzt es gibt
Leute die das sie haben diese mal seine
eigene Meinung und wollen darüber reden
aber sie haben keine Möglichkeit dafür
okay das verstehe ich aber so gibt's
momentan diese Regeln und man sollte die
akzeptieren Zuschauer im eigenen Land
Distanz halten zu den aktuellen
politischen Ereignissen das ist der
sicherste Weg den man in Russland
derzeit einschlagen kann
[Musik]
in Kaliningrad treffe ich zwei Frauen
für die wegschauen keine Option ist die
Anwältinnen Jekaterina seli sarowa und
Maria bonzler verteidigen diejenigen die
wegen der neuen Zensurgesetze vor
Gericht landen die ihre Meinung sagen
obwohl Kritik an der Armee strafbar ist
es sind nicht viele aber es gibt sie sie
können buchstäblich nicht mehr atmen sie
nehmen das alles als Katastrophe war das
raubt ihnen den Atem
sie erzählen mir von einem ihrer
Mandanten
Igor badisch hatte online über den Krieg
über Mario Pohl und Butcher geschrieben
dafür wurde dem Rentner monatelang der
Prozess gemacht
Igor ist schwer krank ausreichend
medizinisch behandelt wurde er lange
nicht
es ist ein Gefühl der völligen
Machtlosigkeit Ohnmacht man kann die
einfachsten Dinge nicht tun einen
postleiten damit das mehr Leute sehen
zum Beispiel plötzlich sitzt du da und
merkst dass du nicht mal mehr das Recht
hast das zu tun dass er dich deswegen
abholen kommen können
mittlerweile ist das Urteil gegen Igor
bodysnikow gefallen der 64-Jährige muss
für siebeneinhalb Jahre in Haft
seit Moskau aus Einmarsch in die Ukraine
sind 20.000 Russinnen und Russen wegen
Äußerungen gegen den Krieg verhaftet
worden etwa 700 wurden zu
Gefängnisstrafen verurteilt andere haben
ihre Jobs verloren oder wurden von der
Uni geworfen
Ausgrenzung ist zur politischen Waffe
gegen Andersdenkende geworden
im Juni feiert das ganze Land den Tag
Russlands alles steht im Zeichen des
Patriotismus auf dem Stadtfest in
Kaliningrad begegnen mir Menschen die
moskausweg unterstützen viele
Kaliningrader gehören dem Militär an
jeder fünfte sei beim Geheimdienst zu
vieles hier klingt als stamme ist direkt
aus einem propaganda-kanal
wir sind alle für den Frieden wir
möchten sehr gerne Frieden aber was soll
man machen jetzt muss man eben den
Faschismus bekämpfen
besser verschiedene russische Regionen
und Ex sowjet-republiken präsentieren
sich auf dem Fest das soll Einigkeit
demonstrieren auch die Ukraine ist mit
einem Stand vertreten
sie alle haben Familie und Freunde in
der Ostukraine um diese sich Sorgen
machen dass sie sich verraten fühlen
erzählen Sie uns von der ukrainischen
Regierung in Kiew
eindeutig trägt nicht das Volk die
Schuld schuldig sind diejenigen die über
uns stehen wir hätten nicht gedacht dass
irgendwer gegen uns sein wird und dann
ausgerechnet die Ukraine das ist das
letzte an dass ich hätte denken können
ging doch dann jetzt verteidigen und die
Krim sonst wären da jetzt längst die
Amerikaner deshalb denke ich dass schon
alles richtig ist die mächtigen machen
lassen und mit den Konsequenzen
irgendwie weiterleben diese Einstellung
wird von klein auf vermittelt und
begegnet uns nicht nur in Kaliningrad
wir reisen nach wieburg dorthin wo
Russland an Finnland und damit
unmittelbar an die NATO grenzt
noch sind nicht alle Folgen die der
Krieg auf die Gesellschaft haben wird
absehbar manche stechen sofort ins Auge
am Strand von bieburg treffe ich eine
Gruppe russischer Soldaten auf
Genesungsurlaub
die Männer haben in der Ostukraine
gekämpft
was ist passiert
eine Drohne ist über meinem Kopf
explodiert Helm und Schädeldecke wurden
durchschlagen
hier sehen sie ein Opfer vom
Raketensystem Heimat wegen der Heimat
hatte ich 12 gebrochene Rippen wenn ich
wieder gesund bin gehe ich zurück egal
ob sie mich wertauglich Stempeln oder
nicht dort gibt es so viele verwundete
deswegen muss ich auf jeden Fall zurück
gehen Russland wird siegen anders kann
es nicht sein bald werden wir unsere
Flagge in kiewissen
wann
der Wald wenn Europa sich nicht beruhigt
marschieren wir weiter dann hissen wir
unsere Flagge auch in Berlin so war es
1945 so wird es 2025 wieder sein
radikale Überzeugungen die Bereitschaft
für moskausziele zu sterben sie mischen
sich zwischen Ausflügler und Familien im
Feierabend
kriegsrückkehrer die getötet haben und
Sterben sahen gehören mittlerweile fest
zu Russlands Alltag
im Zentrum von wieburg lebt und arbeitet
Sava der 34-Jährige hat sich mehrere
Wochen im Wald versteckt um nicht in der
Ukraine kämpfen zu müssen er fühlt sich
isoliert mit seiner kritischen Haltung
die meisten würden einfach mit dem Strom
schwimmen das sei tief im russischen
Volk verankert erklärte mir
in Russland haben die Menschen
schreckliche Angst auf der äußeren Ebene
ist es die Angst vor Instabilität und
vor einer schwebenden Ungewissheit auf
einer tieferen Ebene ist es die Angst
vor der zivilen Verantwortung
deswegen bekäme ein starker Führer vom
Volk viel Zuspruch mein Server egal
welche Richtung der einschlägt seine
Zukunftsprognosen für Russland sind
düster
es gibt zwei Möglichkeiten entweder es
bewegt sich auf eine vollständige totale
Abschottung und Loslösung von der
Außenwelt zu die Nordkorea oder es kommt
zum völligen Zerfall aber niemand weiß
wie das passiert und wann
erstmal profitiert wie Borg von Russland
zunehmender Abschottung der Inlands
Tourismus bubent und so kamen etwa 1,5
Millionen Touristen 2022 in das kleine
Städtchen denen soll eine Besonderheit
wie Box verborgen bleiben
außerhalb der Altstadt Nähe an der
Grenze sind Besucher nicht überall
willkommen westliche Journalisten wie
ich schon mal gar nicht der Geheimdienst
will wissen was wir hier drehen und
erteilt mir schließlich keine
Genehmigung zum Grundstück von Ilias
Laptop zu fahren
mein russisches Team besucht ihn ohne
mich per Telefon sprechen wir über die
finnischen Landhäuser die hier
rekonstruiert
es tut mir leid dass ich heute nicht bei
Ihnen sein kann es kam alles etwas
anders als erwartet
Ilja ist ein erfolgreicher Onkologe er
zeigt meinem Team womit er seit sechs
Jahren jede freie Minute verbringt
Museen und Herbergen sollen hier
entstehen einen Weinkeller gibt es schon
und selbst gebrautes Starkbier der Russe
lässt das finnische Erbe des Dorfes
kieskala wieder aufleben während
zwischen Moskau und Helsinki Eiszeit
herrscht
1000 Jahren mit den Finnen verheiratet
in dieser Zeit ist alles mögliche
passiert aber das ist kein Grund sich
scheiden zu lassen so ist das in einer
Familie
die Hoffnung dass der Krieg bald endet
dass die Beziehungen zu den
Nachbarländern sich wieder normalisieren
sie ist in Russland weit verbreitet die
Ansicht das Moskau an all dem keine
Schuld trägt allerdings auch
ich bin in St Petersburg hier kann der
Anstieg russischer Besucher das
Wegbleiben der vielen westlichen
Touristen nicht ausgleichen so leer habe
ich die Stadt im Sommer noch nie erlebt
lautstark werden Gäste für eine
kanal-tour gesucht
wer braucht diesen Krieg der der Geld
verdienen will Krieg bedeutet Geld
deswegen will keiner aufhören das wird
alles nicht so schnell enden solange man
die Ukraine mit Waffen versorgt wird
alles so weitergehen
auch das ein Teil der russischen
propagandaerzählung doch nicht alle
glauben dem was im Staatsfernsehen rauf
und runterläuft in diesem Hinterhof lebt
das Gewissen von St Petersburg so nennen
Sie Jelena ossipowa hier die 77-Jährige
holt sich nur langsam von einem
Schlaganfall doch sie wollte unser
Treffen partout nicht absagen die
Künstlerin kämpft gegen den Krieg gegen
die Teilnahmslosigkeit ihrer Mitmenschen
auch wenn sie manche Gründe dafür
nachvollziehen kann
es gibt recht viele Menschen die alles
verstehen
sie kommen dann heran zu mir die ich im
Rollstuhl sitze und sagen wenn ich
protestiere verliere ich den Job
verliere ich alles verstehen sie die
Gesetze sind jetzt so geschrieben worden
immer wieder stellt sich Jelena mit
ihren Plakaten auf die Straße alleine
jedes Mal endet das mit einem
Polizeieinsatz wie viele Geldstrafen sie
schon kassiert hat weiß sie nicht
jelenas neueste Botschaft Russland
bedarf einer Rehabilitierung nach
schwerer Krankheit
in welche Richtung hat sich Deutschland
damals bewegt
wir haben jetzt genau die gleiche
schwere Krankheit wie einst Deutschland
wenn alles vorbei sei sagt Jelena werde
es noch lange dauern bis die russische
Gesellschaft geheilt sei
liberale Werte werden von der russischen
Politik verteufelt Freiheiten
abgeschafft immer wieder merke ich wie
sorgsam meine Gesprächspartner ihre
Worte wählen
Vitali will Kapitän werden wir reden
über seine Heimatstadt seine
Zukunftspläne als ich Frage inwiefern
der Krieg sein Leben verändert habe
erzählt Vitali das Kommilitonen von ihm
gefallen sind
das ist natürlich sehr schwer
andererseits worauf die Jungs gehofft
hatten ist unklar vielleicht wollten sie
Geld verdienen vielleicht haben Sie
irgendwelche patriotischen Gefühle
verspürt ich weiß es nicht
das Vitali studiert schützt ihn vor der
Einberufung zur Militär seine getöteten
Kommilitonen hatten sich freiwillig
gemeldet
sie sind natürlich Helden ich will in
keiner Weise ihre Arbeit abwerten
aber es ist doch traurig dass die
Regierung dass die Menschen die sich mit
Politik beschäftigen
es soweit kommen lassen
Vitali ist verheiratet mit einer Ukraine
die 2014 vor den Kämpfen in Johannes
geflohen ist ihre Familie lebt noch dort
bewegt natürlich was sich ereignet wie
wir vorrücken wie die Ukrainer
Vorankommen
diese Nachrichten verfolgen wir aber
ständig in dieser Realität leben das ist
unmöglich zumindest für mich
mein Gehirn schottet sich da irgendwie
ab ich weiß nicht ich denke überhaupt
nicht mehr darüber nach
Ablenkung als Selbstschutz schweigen aus
Angst nach Jahren der Repressionen hat
ein Gefühl der Machtlosigkeit viele
Russinnen und Russen fest im Griff ob St
Petersburg wieburg oder Kaliningrad
einst war die Ostseeküste Schauplatz des
internationalen Miteinanders jetzt wird
Russlands Abschottung von seinen
europäischen Nachbarn hier besonders
deutlich
[Musik]
die Ostsee das ruhige Gewässer wird zum
Schauplatz eines gefährlichen
machtpokers die ganze Dokumentation dazu
in der ZDFmediathek
die Angst vor der russischen Aggression
nimmt vor allem in ehemaligen
sowjet-staaten wieder zu viele fragen
sich was passiert wenn der alte Besatzer
Russland wiederkommt genau diese Frage
hat meine Kollegin Natalie Steger im
Baltikum gestellt